in the last 24 hours 963
people have been evacuated from kabul on
the royal air force airbridge
that's a significant acceleration on the
numbers over the previous 24 hours and
reflects i think that we're now fully up
to speed in kabul uh with military
border force and foreign office consular
staff all now up and running uh and
we're looking forward to delivering
similar numbers today tomorrow and over
the days ahead so on that basis how long
will the uk evacuation plan last
well i mean we don't have it in our
gifts to say that it will last for
another
five days 10 days 15 days it is clearly
uh circumstances that are very dynamic
uh we are simply doing our best to
maximize flow each and every day but as
my colleague the defense secretary has
sadly had to say on a number of
occasions the reality is that eventually
the air bridge will have to close and
quite possibly not everybody will have
been got out that's what keeps us awake
at night that's what's motivating to us
to work as hard as we are to ensure that
those numbers are the absolute minimum
i mean what what does other people do
who aren't at the airport at the moment
one of our correspondents has been
talking to the sahiri family from london
who 13 of them went over there for for a
wedding they're in kabul they can't at
the moment get to the airport
what are the options for people like
that
so i think i'd say three things if i may
firstly uh
our understanding is that actually the
taliban are not
uh turning people away uh where they
have done i've heard that it's more that
they are being officious rather than
malicious
and so if people are called forward for
flights they should have confidence that
the taliban will let them through uh to
the handling center we know that the
crowds outside the handling center have
been a barrier for many uh yesterday we
reconfigured uh the handling center uh
did some military engineering to try to
ease those cruel control challenges
which hopefully will increase flow and
then the final thing i would say is that
people should not despair that the air
bridge is their one route out of
afghanistan to the united kingdom there
will be a second phase to this operation
which will see people being able to
enroll at other british embassies and
high commissions in the region and to be
able to be resettled that way and so
even when the air bridge inevitably has
to close that's not the end of people's
chances of getting to the uk
i mean the reports that the contract
staff who protected the british embassy
are now getting no protection from great
britain labor calls that shameful
that's got to be looked at hasn't it
well if you're referring to the gaada
world staff who protect the embassy i
can tell you that they
have arrived at the airport this morning
and we'll be moving them out later today
so they they are now fully covered
yes yes um in terms of of getting people
out that we have relied on
during our time in afghanistan i mean
why did the foreign secretary not take
our responsibility
to get interpreters out of afghanistan
seriously enough to take a phone call
well i don't know the exact details of
foreign office ministers call sheets
what i can tell you as the secretary of
state said yesterday
i know that no one phone call would have
been decisive in changing the trajectory
either for the collapse of the afghan
government or indeed for the
acceleration of the airlift what i'm
focused on is not recrimination over who
should and shouldn't have done what when
i'm focused
every single minute of every single day
in making sure that the military
operation to extract people from kabul
goes as well as it possibly can and that
we leave as few people behind as
possible but if you're focused on that
every minute of every day you'd expect
your colleagues to to do the same
wouldn't you if the foreign secretary
wouldn't make a phone call or take a
phone call and it's passed on to his
junior and that phone call still doesn't
take place if the defense secretary um
said to as he said we knew that the
afghan government was melting like ice
on friday and yet the prime minister
then heads off on holiday on saturday i
mean it does raise questions doesn't it
about the commitment of your colleagues
i can only tell you what i see in the
meetings and phone calls that i have uh
all the way through every day have done
for the last week will do for the next
one and what i see is that from the
prime minister to secretaries of state
to my junior ministerial colleagues
around government to senior civil
servants all the way down to the brave
volunteer civil servants who have gone
forward to cabal from the border force
from the mod and from the foreign office
is people across the majesties
government working their backsides off
in order to get people out i completely
understand why the media wants to
ask these sorts of questions it's
entirely reasonable but you'll forgive
me perhaps if i focus on the job at hand
and hopefully be reassured if i tell you
that absolutely every colleague at every
level be they political military or
civil service is doing everything they
possibly can to make sure that we get as
many people out as quickly as we
possibly can i mean you served you've
got a better understanding of this and
certainly a lot of your colleagues who
haven't served and done a tour of duty
in
afghanistan everyone's talking about
being blindsided by this and certainly
it was a very rapid
operation by the taliban but um
it's emerged in a report submitted to
the government in january it laid out
how what sort of risks the u.s
withdrawal posed to all of this so
there's been eight months of planning
time
so why has the uk government let's
forget about every other country why is
the uk government been blindsided by
this
well i don't think i accept that
characterization of what's happened over
the last week absolutely we've been
blindsided by the speed of the collapse
of the afghan government and the speed
at which the taliban have been able to
take control but
there was a plan for the drawdown of
british troops in afghanistan called op
catalon that has been in place since the
beginning of last year because the doha
agreement that president trump signed
meant that on the first of may this year
in theory we were going to be leaving
and so we've had a plan for that all
along likewise op pitting which is the
evacuation of entitled personnel and
those who have worked alongside us
that's the plan of long-standing so both
of the plans that have been executed
over the last few months and are in
progress right now in the terms of
pitting have long since been devised and
we're ready to go the bit that's caught
us out and i don't think anybody uh can
uh
deny this is that everything happened
far more quickly than we ever thought it
would
um
as a
a veteran of afghanistan what did you
make of general cynic carter chief of
the defense staff who said on this
program a couple of days ago the taliban
are country lads with a a moral code not
our enemy
i'm obviously
not quoting him directly there but those
are the words he said what impact does
that have on veterans what impact does
it have on the families of the
457
what impact does it have on serving
armed forces personnel
well i think that
actually to veterans and to serving
personnel um we're probably the audience
that gets what cvs was saying more than
anybody else because
you know the three operational campaigns
that i served in northern ireland iraq
and two tours to afghanistan in northern
ireland by the end people like jerry
adams and martin mcginnis who had been
in the ira were a part of government
in iraq people like mukhtar al-sadr who
was the leader
forgive me forgive me minister for
jumping in but we are a bit tight for
time look i've been in contact with a
lot of members of the armed forces over
the past few days they're not on board
with what the chief of the defense staff
was saying they're absolutely furious
morale is at rock bottom and you only
have to look at what was posted on
forces tv on when they played out our
interview on on instagram and look at
the hundreds of comments below to see if
people are not on board with this
whether they're currently serving or
veterans they're furious
well i think you you should let me make
the point that i was making which is
that we get that when we go off to fight
we are
a means to an end but we are not the end
in itself and that very often the piece
that follows that is imperfect and just
as members of the ira are now in
government in northern ireland the
people who are leading the insurgency
that we were fighting in iraq are now
the key power brokers for a government
that we're working with in baghdad it
was always inevitable that the taliban
would be part of the solution in
afghanistan it makes me sick of course
it does to see the scenes that we're
seeing in afghanistan i gave some of the
best years of my life and i risked my
life
in afghanistan but when i was patrolling
in sangin in 2009 or in kabul in 2005 i
was doing my best to make a difference
in those six months to the lives of the
people that lived in those communities
what's happening now is for politicians
to answer for but the fact that the
taliban are part of the piece as painful
as that is for people like me who have
served it was always going to be the
reality
what would you say though to the mother
of a young soldier who lost their lives
in afghanistan you know i don't know
eight years ago
when they hear
cynic carter say these are country lads
with a moral code
but i have been at many military
funerals i have held the hand of
bereaved mothers when they've been
presented with their elizabeth cross
i have already many times had to look
people in the eye and reassure them that
the sacrifice that their son made was
not in vain i don't think that anything
that has happened over the last week in
any way detracts from what our brave
service men and women did in those
extraordinary years whilst we were in
hellmann and my message to veterans
to the bereaved families of those who
never came home is that they should
continue to take pride in the bravery
and the sacrifice of their loved ones
because they did an amazing job whilst
we were in afghanistan nothing can ever
take that away from them politicians
will be held to account for the outcome
but nothing diminishes
the bravery the courage the
determination the professionalism and
too many cases the sacrifice that our
people put in during those difficult
years in helmand
minister thanks for your time
thank you